interesting we're doing the story today
brian because this happened to me last
night got a flat tire
because the heat is back and that means
you might want to make sure that your
car is up for the challenge
we're going to go help her fix her car
the commercial break a good time to
check your tires
avoid any scares on the road christian
castro is joining us live with some tips
on how to stay safe
and save money
all right guys well it's no secret
summer is right around the corner and
that's usually the busiest time for many
tire shops
today we stopped by one local shop who
tells us the best time to prepare
your vehicle for the summer is actually
now so many of you are probably asking
yourself
how do i do this and it's quite simple
let me show you all you need to do
is go in front of your car look at your
tire and all the information that you
need
is clearly marked around the tire so you
really can't go wrong
now check out this video that we have
today we stopped by this express tire
shop on decatur and reno
and they tell us that the very first
step is to inspect your tires on a
regular base the recommendation
is once a month they say the average
life of a tire is about five to six
years
but right here in the desert the extreme
heat will that will reduce it down
to about four years brands and prices
they say
doesn't it doesn't really matter too
much because they say the heat will
basically deteriorate them very quickly
also tire rotations are very important a
pothole or other road hazards can cause
alignment issues
which could lead to pulling or uneven
trend wear
you can see it's pretty deep for a tire
but this is what affects it um
probably the best thing
is to check the year so you have the
first two numbers in this circle
are going to be the week the tire was
made the last two is going to be the
year
so this one was made in the 35th week of
2016.
not that long ago but you know those
five years
really dry rotted it
well according to the u.s tire
manufacturers association tire pressure
is key to enhance control and
performance
and listen to this maximize fuel meaning
it could save you money
now tire rotation should be done every
five to eight thousand miles
and remember if you're ever an emergency
while traveling you are all
you're asked to call 9-1-1 and wait for
assistance now another quick way to
check if your tire
needs to be replaced the good
old-fashioned penny trick
you just get a penny flip it over and
you just put it down in your tire if you
can see lincoln's head
basically that means that you need to
change your tire if you don't see it
that means it's still pretty good
for a while so there you go some news
you can use